dans quelques jours va sortir le 38e
album d'astérix les chiffres donnent le
tournis un tirage à 5 millions
d'exemplaires un album traduit dans 15
langues
le nom de cet album c'est la fille de
vercingétorix
alors cette fille elle s'appelle
adrénaline elle ressemble un peu à greta
de son bec peut-être que ça va plaire à
lui suggère alors évidemment ça n'est
pas ce ne sont plus les auteurs les
parents d'astérix goscinny et uderzo qui
ont fait cet album mais néanmoins anne
goscinny la fille de rené goscinny
considère que le personnage est fidèle à
l'oeuvre de son père pense que
l'adrénaline est certes dans l'air du
temps
mais quelle et surtout parfaitement en
adéquation avec avec l'esprit de
l'oeuvre avec
l'humour avec les aventures d'astérix en
général et c'est presque un personnage
que mon père aurait pu inventer alors
son père aurait peut-être pu l'inventer
mais il n'est pas si fréquent qui est
une héroïne pour un album d'astérix
parce que dans le temps c'était
peut-être pas aussi évident que ça
écoutez le jean yves ferri et didier
conrad qui sont respectivement
l'auteur des textes et des dessins de
cet album c'est pas vraiment oublier
astérix est liée à la bd des années
60-70 pratiquement jamais personnages
féminins pour des raisons purement
stratégiques ont fait et aussi de
lectorat
c'était il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
filles qui lisez ou en tout cas ça se
savait pas si élise est ce que vous
allez le lire cet album
gabriel plus elle est forcée de le lire
parce que mes enfants vont le faire
acheter donc oui alors je m'appelle je
m'interroge un petit peu que veut-elle
dire
anne goscinny quand elle dit un album
dans l'air du temps alors ça peut
susciter certaines inquiétudes
alors en effet une wii on voit beaucoup
de choses dans l'air du temps
en effet on voit bien qu'on fait une
référence en effet à l'air du temps
prenant une héroïne féminine et en lui
attribuant de l'adrénaline peut-être lié
à la testostérone habituellement
néanmois je m'étonne un petit peu de
cette réflexion parce que c'est bien
falbala je m'attendais a écrit qu'ils
tiraient beaucoup de ficelle quand même
dans de nombreux albums donc je ne suis
pas tout à fait sûr qu'elle est tu
qu'elle est eu un rôle mineur cela dit
moi je me réjouis toujours de la sortie
d'un nouvel astérix parce que je la fais
partie de notre identité et j'avais bien
tout ce qu'ils cultivent les identités
et vous gardez kuzmanovic vous aurez
envie de lire cet album
pareillement âgée des filles celles
auxquelles elle aime bien moi j'avais
beaucoup astérix et obélix
gamin j'ai un peu décroché une fois que
l'ancien d'esprit était un peu partie
parce que quand même y avait un humour
particulièrement ingrat 100 films
plusieurs degrés c'est un peu s'est un
peu étiolé
je trouve c'est un peu plus du front
alors on verra un peu mois de siège
voilà un peu moins deuxième degré et
puis enfin il il osait dire des choses
intéressantes
et puis c'est intéressant on n'a pas le
droit on est un village gaulois qui
résiste cette union européenne qui fait
pression afin de points c'est bien mais
encore quelques-uns qui défendent leur
souveraineté
lucile schmid oui moi je l'assumé et je
pense que si je le lis ça sera pas mes
enfants qui me le demandent et je pense
qu'ils connaissent beaucoup un astérix
et obélix que moi je pense que pour eux
c'est beaucoup moins important moi
j'avais j'ai adoré exemple le domaine
des dieux qui mettait en scène la lutte
contre la promotion immobilière et je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez il y
avait des chaînes qui poussaient en dix
minutes
non mais non même cinq secondes parce
qu'ils étaient gorgés la potion magique
donc je trouve ça absolument génial
après la j'écoutais je me disais c'est
quand même une autre étape parce que
cette adrénaline fille de vincent j'ai
tout risqué quand même un truc assez
bizarre moi je suis pas sûr que
remettent une femme au centre
moi je suis une femme mais j'aimais bien
le côté très masculin en fait assez
viril donc j'espère qu'elle sera elle
sera pleine de force et j'espère qu'il y
aura aussi quand même ce truc de
messages politiques qui avaient parfois
cet humour corrosif qui avait parce que
si c'est consensuel
ça m'ennuie en fait et je trouve que les
derniers étaient complètement raté ça
alors donc on en a profité pour vous
demander quelles étaient vos vous votre
album préféré donc vous venez de
répondre cher lucile s'il est donc le
domaine des dieux avec donc un
maastricht historique avec uderzo et
goscinny
d'après cluzel qu'est ce que c'est votre
arme préférée aussi le premier tour de
gaule autour de huy visite toutes les
régions de france en ce qu'il ramène
toutes les places c'est sûr et alors
pour terminer ce tour de table
nous avons trouvé la perle rare
la femme qui n'a jamais d'astérix
refaire je ne sais pas mais non ça n'a
pas dû nous a pas montré en fond et je
les ratés mais maintenant je vais bien
tiré oui j'avais mal ils n'ont peut-être
pas parce que j'ai trouvé le discours
très marketing ne sais pas ce que je
vais commencer par les historiques alors
le candide nos internautes
alors lire et vous la fille de
vercingétorix et le prochain astérix
c'est oui à 42% et non à 58 %
gabriel cluzel est ce que vous partagez
le la vie georgia kuzmanovic selon
lesquelles les derniers albums sont
peut-être un petit peu plus il n'a pas
dit politiquement correct mais vers
l'axé moins invasif que les premiers
mais malheureusement je crois que ça
c'est très compliqué de résister moi je
vois ça dans la littérature enfantine on
se moquait beaucoup une 19e vous savez
de la littérature de sacristie très
sucré avec toujours faire de bons
sentiments et on a troqué une morale
pour une autre je suis frappé vraiment
de quand j'achète des livres pour mes
enfants me rends compte que c'est
extrêmement lisse et qu'il ya des
messages politiquement correct gros
comme des mammouths au milieu des pages
qui tendent à enlever de la légèreté à
l'histoire
alors qu'est ce que vous avez envie d'en
faire un lieu du coup alors moi j'ai
quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup je
suis peut-être la seule c'est une
infinie histoire d'un petit garçon qui
s'appelle bennett j'ai pas si vous avez
lu bennett bennett recoller bah oui avec
cendres avec sa casquette et c'est plein
d'humour ça a été traduit par le père de
renault le père et qui s'appelle olivier
ses champs et par vladimir volkoff qui
tous les deux été traducteur
moi j'aime bien quand les livres sont
anglais mais qui a des traducteurs de
qualité parce que ça donne une qualité
de la langue intéressante il faut
surtout acheté les vieilles éditions
payer son côté écolo parce que les
nouvelles les nouvelles tendent à penser
que les enfants peut-être moins de
vocabulaire et à temps à faire des
phrases plus simple je préfère les
anciennes éditions
et bien voilà une recommandation de
lecture merci beaucoup merci à tous les
4 mois je n'ai pas lu ce cet album comme
je pense vous même donc je ne peux pas
me prononcer mais on ne manquera pas de
vous tient au corps pour savoir si on a
aimé ou non la fille
vercingétorix et donc le prochain
astérix qui sort dans une semaine merci
beaucoup à tous bon soir
[Musique]